it feels as though the next leadership
contest is going to be among women and
the most obvious contenders are sella
bravman KY Bok I don't know about Liz
truss maybe pretty Patel on behalf of
Liz truss and then Penny Morton so it's
it's all about the women at the moment
which is is a fascinating Dynamic but I
think s bravman is is establishing
herself as the natural leader of the
populace and of course commentators
always say she's doing dog whistle or
she's saying this to get votes or that
was a leadership election speech yeah it
was but she also believes in it and I
think of all the people who I've spoken
to in the course of this week I think
the person who is most philosophically
coherent and consistent is probably
sella bravman and is probably the one
who touches Accord best with the public
I still think she has some space to grow
as a political figure and as a a
political actor but nonetheless I think
the new conservative whatever they call
themselves movement I think that's
probably more likely to win votes in the
future than populist neoliberalism